[Musique]
Donald Trump vient d'être inculpé pour
la quatrième fois en 6 mois malgré sa
lourde actualité judiciaire rien ne
l'empêche d'être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de 2024 une campagne qui
s'annonce inédite historique entre
meeting et procès alors Donald Trump
pourra-t-il faire campagne le fera t-il
depuis la prison en réalité ces
inculpations ne seraient-elles pas
bénéfiques pour Donald Trump réponse
dans factures 30 mars 2023 Donald Trump
est accusé d'avoir acheté le silence
d'une actrice de film X quelques mois
plus tard le 8 juin il est mise en
accusation pour sa présumée négligence
dans la gestion de documents
confidentiels puis le 3 août il est
soupçonné d'avoir manipulé les scrutins
de plusieurs états après l'élection
présidentielle de 2020 pour autant le
milliardaire reste le principal rival de
Joe Biden pour la prochaine élection à
moins que il y a un cas de figure où il
ne pourrait pas se présenter alors on va
mettre du conditionnel partout mais
d'après effectivement les
constitutionnalistes américain
cette Donald Trump il était condamné
pour insurrection au rébellion tomberait
sous le coup de ce fameux amendement 14
de la Constitution américaine et
l'empêcherait de pouvoir se présenter
alors face à une possible condamnation
Donald Trump a une stratégie jouer la
montre la justice américaine est très
longue ordinaire et donc toute la main
d'oeuvre des avocats de Donald Trump ça
va être de retarder le plus possible
l'ouverture des procès pour que si
possible ces procès ne commencent
qu'après l'élection présidentielle et
les avocats se disent Donald Trump à ce
moment-là sera président il y aura un
nouveau ministre de la Justice et on
pourra faire jouer l'immunité
présidentielle donc la campagne de
Donald Trump aura sans doute lieu
parallèlement à ces différents procès le
temps judiciaire va se poursuivre tout
le long de la fin de l'année 2023 du
début de l'année 2024 donc va télescoper
l'agenda de Donald Trump et Donald Trump
va passer son temps entre les tribunaux
les émissions télévisions et les
meetings les mythiques en campagne pour
la plupart des hommes politiques quatre
inculpations portant sur 91 chefs
d'accusation sonnerait la fin d'une
carrière pour Donald Trump cette
situation est plutôt favorable disons
que Donald Trump
avait pour culture historique on va dire
de considérer que toute publicité il n'y
a pas de mauvaise publicité toute
publicité est une bonne publicité et il
poursuit un petit peu dans cette logique
au-delà même de ce qu'on a vu la
campagne est d'ailleurs officiellement
débuté le mercredi 23 août avec le
premier débat des républicains
événements clés Donald Trump a décidé de
boycotter ses avocats
spagnes il ne faut pas y aller il a
hésité je peux vous donner comme
information que la PDG de Fox News a été
déjeuné chez Donald Trump la semaine
dernière en lui disant j'espère que vous
allez vraiment participer au débat parce
qu'au nom de la démocratie c'est
extrêmement important que tous les
candidats soient là mais il n'a pas
écouté cette femme qui dirige Fox News
et il a décidé de ne pas y aller Paris
de Trump c'est que ces électeurs le
connaissent déjà par cœur il a été
président pendant quatre ans de fait il
semble dans les sondages que les
poursuits contre Trump c'est pas
qu'elles n'ont pas d'effets mais c'est
qu'elles ne changent pas vraiment
l'opinion que les gens ont déjà de lui
c'est à dire que à peu près tous les
Américains ont déjà une opinion sur
Donald Trump et s'il a fait ce choix
fort c'est qu'il peut se le permettre
dans les sondages Donald Trump devance
tous ses concurrents aujourd'hui dans
quelques jours après la dernière
inculpation sur l'affaire géorgienne il
a maintenant dépassé le cadre des 40
points d'avance sur son deuxième
poursuivant qui est l'homme de Santis si
Trump parvient s'imposer comme le
candidat républicain pour 2024 a-t-il
des chances d'être à nouveau élu
président de la République sa Joe Biden
le chiffre
que 60% des Américains entre 55 à 60%
qui ne veulent ni de Joe Biden ni de
Donald Trump pourquoi et chaque fois
qu'on les interroge ils disent ils sont
trop vieux on en a assez on aspire au
calme puis 2016 il fait de la politique
sous la marque Trump il estime que peu
importe son programme d'ailleurs son
programme il l'a en gros résumé d'un mot
ça sera la revanche le programme je
serai votre vengeance je serai votre
votre revanche a-t-il dit à ses
supporters la majorité des Américains ne
n'est pas contente du choix proposé mais
si l'élection présidentielle américaine
avait lieu demain vraisemblablement à
quelques voies près et bien Donald Trump
serait sans doute le nouveau président
des États-Unis